thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
of the sexual experience would ask the
young lady who's your daddy this should
be remixed if officer akimov is watching
this could be the next remix Masterpiece
just because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here uh that's beautiful
who's your daddy who's your dad I'm
joined today by Pastor James David
Manning
no I'm a Christian
[Music]
who's your dad I'm joined today by
Pastor James David Manning
[Music]
a Long Legged Mack Daddy is the most
successful pimp on planet Earth to
reverence the word of God to trust it to
preach it to teach it
Loaves and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies what happened in prison
that brought you to Jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to Jesus
[Music]
watch Bush and George Bush Jr have been
penetrated by at least 100 men in their
anus a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand strong I didn't do it that's
not my problem well I got down on my
knees
I didn't do it but I was tempted sounds
like quite an evening
[Music]
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of Life
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of live
lows and loads of money and tons and
tons of life
I didn't say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
Starbucks has done the exact same thing
that Coca-Cola has done except they've
done it we've seen it that certainly
seems to be a story that has been missed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms we're
here much earlier than normal because
the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is going to be addressing a
they're calling it a joint session of
U.S Congress but really it doesn't seem
to be I gotta look at the room that
they're in and as you can see here we
see Amy Klobuchar and a number of other
people but it's a different room and
zelenski will be addressing both the
Senate and a house in a separate room
um via video conference we might call it
uh
cyberly he will be addressing them
cyberly I think is the best way to say
it and I'm I'm as curious as anybody
else to see what uh the Ukrainian
President says over the last not even 24
really more like 12 hours actually
uh we have seen news that Russia has
lost a fourth General uh through a
combination of getting killed and
resignation although Russia has not yet
confirmed all four of those
um we have seen China say they are open
to supporting Russia militarily and
financially
um we have seen what else have we seen
we we've we've seen a report that Russia
can't really do more than 10 days of
this without help from the outside due
to declining resources and attrition and
so on and so forth so it'll be very
interesting to see what the Russian uh
with the Ukrainian president rather says
and we are monitoring multiple streams
again you see uh Minnesota senator Amy
Klobuchar there and this is a picture of
zelenski and that's a picture of
zelenski and that's a picture of
zelenski and then here this is the ABC
news feed awaiting I think we'll stick
here because we see what's going on in
the room
uh why not why not
um and uh it's all it's all happening
here
um thank you to Skittle Stu and Jen here
for gifting three Subs between the two
of them I really appreciate that yeah I
don't you know I I said I might stream
this and at least like one person said
they wanted me to so we rearranged our
day in order to do it I don't know if
we'll get any kind of serious audience
today you know a lot of a lot of the
people who watch our show are still
sleeping uh even on the East Coast but
certainly on the west coast so we will
uh we we will track all of that very
very closely before we jump into some
clips and different things I did get an
early morning voicemail from Whitney
which I want to listen to
foreign
like they're supposed to like go on
pretending like unlike something else
and like you're
you're like not even supposed to think
of me doing the human like things
no Whitney I think of you as a human
don't worry about that that's fine uh
okay let's see um one interesting bit of
news is that crude oil I believe this is
light sweet crude although it might be
salted caramel or caramel
crude I don't remember which flavor this
is it's actually down dramatically off
of its eyes as you can see uh peaking at
around 126 dollars per barrel
um now about 10 days ago and we have
seen a significant decline all the way
down to 97 per barrel which is not that
far uh from where it was for for quite a
period of time and so this crude oil is
a Futures market and
um this would potentially signal
beliefs and expectations about how long
the Russia Ukraine conflict will go on
but that all it is is a guess that
that's really all it is
um and we're going to continue watching
that here's something you guys might
find interesting I'm going to be
covering this on today's podcast which I
have not yet recorded we've rearranged
our we've whoa that knocked my hair out
of alignment we've rearranged our whole
schedule today in order to accommodate
this very powerful stream this morning
um so we will uh we we will take a look
at that this is Herschel Walker who is a
trump endorsed Senate candidate in
Georgia he has come up with the
brilliant of evolutionary Insight of If
evolution is real why are there still
monkeys this is a lot of people aren't
asking this question guys take a listen
to this hear that means somebody up
there had to say let there be light that
the earth started and then he had to put
someone there on Earth because remember
Adam was there
remember Adam came there then Eve came
so somebody had to start it out right so
that means it had to be a God because it
needs a some bomb blew up and it started
out and then I'll tell you something
else I heard now think about this please
because at one time the sign said man
came from AIDS did it not
I've heard that when you go to the side
every time I read or hear that I think
to myself you just didn't read the same
Bible I did well what this was
interesting the shame but why do all of
these right-wing nuts speak that way
it's the Alex Jones thing the shame
Bible
if that is true why are there still Apes
right
right
think about it you know now you're
getting too smart for it no no no no
think about this we have an evolution
that is we've gotten so intelligent that
if that is true why are there still apes
and then the conception of a baby right
right now this man
could be one of 100 senators
331 million people in the United States
100 Senators out of 331 million people
this guy could be one out of a hundred
pulled from 331 million people
okay now of course you may know the
answer if we evolved from apes why are
there still Apes
modern apes and modern humans evolved
from an older common ancestor
I mean it's you know
very very weaponized delusions there and
uh again what does it say about our
country if one out of 100 I mean maybe
there's more maybe there's more of the
hundred that believe this but if we say
we only get a hundred senators and we
can pick from 331 million people not
literally because you know kids okay
um
but this guy and that's a good point why
do we still have why hold on let's see
where is that what if dogs came from
wolves
why are there still wolves
I don't know guys I don't know these are
these are questions a lot of they don't
the next thing they'll say is you're not
allowed to ask these questions it's like
no you are they're just very dumb
questions most seven-year-olds ask these
questions when they're taught about
evolution
and then we move on okay I want to say
thank you to stuck a duck for the twitch
Prime subscription thank you very much I
appreciate it we are standing by for a
speech from the Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski we are monitoring
five different feeds only one of which
is really showing us anything of uh
anything of Interest today's themed
coupon code is please don't War we want
an end to the invasion obviously you can
use that coupon code on my website the
first person to do so at joinpakman.com
will get a free item from my online
store whoever is the first to use the
code please don't War there is the vile
and disgusting Raphael Cruz Senator goes
by Ted he is presumably not in Cancun he
is looking particularly gross and
disgusting uh on this uh on this
Wednesday morning
and we will we will monitor him
for uh signs of idiocy
um let's see I think I have a couple
other Clips here
oh um yeah you guys may have heard of
this again this will be on today's
podcast Russia has sanctioned and banned
Joe Biden Hillary Clinton Hunter Biden
Jen Saki and others they are not allowed
to go to Russia they don't they're not
allowed to have bank accounts in Russia
they're not allowed to do business with
Russia jensaki was asked about it and
here's what she had to say
sanctions sure we're imposed today by
Russia against yourself President Biden
and other top U.S officials do you have
a response to that and how will it
impact any of you if at all sure I would
first note that President Biden is a
junior so they may have may have
sanctioned his dad may he rest in peace
um the second piece I would say is that
won't surprise any of you that none of
us are planning uh tourist trips to
Russia and none of us have bank accounts
that we won't be able to access so we
will Forge ahead okay so they're going
to be able to continue they're gonna
they're gonna be able to proceed please
proceed Governor exactly without too
much impact from that
um here is an example of someone who has
completely lost any connection to
reality here is Lara Logan remember when
Lara Logan was not a right wing nut well
I barely do Lara Logan is now a
right-wing nut she appeared on real
America's voice to explain
why uh zielinski is bad and she did some
thinly veiled anti-Semitism and also
talked about how there's a lot of occult
stuff going on in Ukraine very very sick
woman listen to this what troubles me
about the moment that we're in is that
we have such a selective and a narrow
reading
you know president
be Jewish but he's not the only one in
this who suffered during right what
he may be Jewish
but other people have suffered too guys
let's not think that anti-Semitism is
really that bad
like who else who else has suffered the
second world war whose ancestors
suffered right I mean look at Putin oh
listen zelenski may be Jewish and his
family may have suffered when the Nazis
tried to kill all the Jews
but Vlad has suffered two guys how many
relatives did he lose in the siege of
Saint Petersburg people don't know their
history they don't know what made
Vladimir Putin and I'm not a defend you
know I'm not defending him I don't need
to defend Vladimir my job as a
journalist is to try to understand what
is the truth here I don't like being
lied to and we're being lied to on an
epic scale when we're told your only
choices you have to be a hundred percent
with zelenski who's a puppet who you can
find on the internet in black stilettos
and leather pants you know with
shirtless doing a spoof Dancing with the
Stars kind of entertainment video that's
a mock of a Ukrainian group that does
this kind of satanic occult type of
music listen guys on the one hand Russia
invaded Ukraine is killing people bombed
a Maternity Ward bombed an orphanage
um isn't respecting the sovereignty of
Ukrainian borders but there is a satanic
occult Entertainment Group in Ukraine
you know I mean I don't know video and I
mean zielinski was selected like so many
of our leaders and honestly with with
big Tech and with election fraud these
days we don't know how many leaders all
around the world have been selected
there's no evidence
that zielinski won unfairly because of
big Tech or fraud
there's just no evidence of that here's
one more where she goes in on the occult
stuff
then in front of the world as being you
know such an example of Ukraine's
Independence and spirit and nobility
even they are wearing the black son of
the occult I mean there's a lot of
occult stuff going on there guys that's
that's the bottom line so Lara Logan um
uh completely losing her mind on live
television thank you to Sven Hout for
gifting to subscriptions on Twitch the
winner of the free item from my store is
Ron Roth first to use the code please
don't war on my website today Ron please
email info davidpackman.com let us know
what item you'd like from my online
store let us know your address and we
will get that out to you also a big
thank you to Jennifer wall Brown as well
as Trevor Hamilton both signing up on my
website new members eight and nine today
with the coupon code please don't War
please don't war and lastly a huge thank
you to guitar goddess now resubscribed
for 18 months via twitch Prime
uh I missed a Super Chat here it is why
wasn't Trump banned when he was so hard
on Russia I I know I know you know
Hillary Clinton got sanctioned Joe Biden
got sanctioned Hunter Biden got
sanctioned Anthony blinken jensaki got
sanctioned and banned by Russia Trump
wasn't banned and nobody was tougher uh
on Russia than Trump
uh yeah
let's see there was one other Super Chat
here that I think I missed here's some
coffee money keep up the great work
David oh that's from KB thank you KB
very much appreciate that thank you well
thank you very much everybody
uh we are standing by here for Vladimir
zielinski due to speak
in about nine minutes nine minutes from
now let's actually let's put together a
tweet
about that I like that topic let's see
how let's craft the Tweet okay so
um
it's weird that Trump wasn't sanctioned
by and banned from Russia given that no
one was tougher on
Russia than him
right
okay
um very strong Super Chat from Jamie
Ward with no message no message all
right well welcome welcome everybody
come on in we are moments away there is
Nancy Pelosi we see Mitch McConnell over
here standing very very strongly
awaiting a speech from the Ukrainian
President Vladimir zelensky
um awaiting an address
Tyler says the entire mainstream media
safe for print is ignoring Ginny Thomas
story embarrassing saki refused to
comment when will you cover it we will
cover it today I have a story about the
Clarence Thomas Jenny Thomas thing on
today's podcast and in addition we will
be covering it on the uh bonus show
so a lot a lot a lot going on of course
the bonus show is dangerous oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
it makes money to fund themselves as bad
if there is any better endorsement of
the bonus show than the fact that Alex
Jones hates the bonus show I don't know
what it is and that's one of the
benefits that you get when you sign up
on my website
uh let's see other super chats can we
hear Trump saying obana it always makes
my day of course Rachel let's kick it
this is an early morning Obama
thank you very
it there is something about it that's
just perfect I don't know what it is but
it's very very nice
um
let's see a couple other voicemails
so I think I found a reason why I
couldn't get an inmate while Trump was
president
so I think that Trump was kind of making
it seemed like sort of like okay well
maybe there's like some people that are
like Pro
uh
Nazi like they were um one side of the
argument and maybe we were like kind of
like good people and you know maybe some
of these other people on the other side
that are like good people too
um sort of thing like you know if
there's something that looks Nazi lying
around that doesn't really mean it's
necessarily good or bad
um all right we're I think we're going
to get away from that
uh
uh yeah
there's Chuck Grassley entering the
chamber to discharge his duty as a
member of the U.S Senate Tristan says
you being on in the morning is the best
thing since sliced Obama thank you
John says sir you're going to cover the
Tennessee town that was asked to
dissolve its Town Charter haven't heard
of it you know we can't cover every
story I don't know if that I don't know
if that's a story for us I'll check it
out but you know we can't we can't cover
every story if you could interview Trump
what would be something you asked him
what would you want to walk away from
the interview with I don't know those
questions are so tough because I I have
no idea what I would ask Trump
um it's very it's hard to pick just one
thing you know very very tough I'd come
up with something for sure
uh still standing by for Vladimir
zielinski's address coming any moment
people don't talk about it but Trump
actually called to ban Putin from Russia
along with all men and we will ban men
right
right
no that's a that's a serious issue
that's a very very serious issue for
sure people don't talk about it and it's
really a shame
as we like to say
let's see if I've got
anything else for you guys as far as
voicemails go
um
what else do we have here
hello hello I was wondering why with all
these sanctions and all this [ __ ]
that you know the Russians are still
getting gas for 50 cents a leader
you know which only makes it about two
dollars a gallon
you know I know they they may they may
have time rough but you know they got
gas
okay yep no that's true they definitely
have gas in Russia how long until the
right starts praising Biden for getting
oil below 100 bucks never
never
how rich that the trumpers are making
fun of zelenski's background and
qualifications to be leader of an Asian
I know it's like the reality show host
who built a business with his dad's
money and the business didn't do as well
as just sticking the money in the S P
500 for 40 years the people that voted
for that guy are saying zelenski's not
really qualified to be president
Lucian says sir this must be very early
for you but a very good timing for here
in Europe really appreciate your efforts
thank you Lucian I'm thrilled to be here
I really am and uh it's it's all it's
all happening I don't know what else to
say but it really is it's an incredible
day
Grayson says thanks for all you do must
make hot food now I think I still have
that on my uh
let's see where is my hot food
around noon
warm food around noon yeah
man those were the days those were the
days uh that was that was a different
era it was a simpler time I guess uh I
guess we would say
uh due in three minutes here is
President zielinski let's make sure we
have all of the streams being monitored
I believe we do we'll stick here for now
um yeah zelenski is not in DC this is
via teleconference via teleconference
um what's the most twitch Subs ever
donated so I don't so the most twitch
Subs ever donated in one tranche is 50.
the most donated ever is 555 by I'm in
consolable and then 363 by a user who
goes by David chadman followed by 258 by
someone who goes by the name spudnicks
Spud like a potato Spud so 50 is the
record at once and 555 is the I guess we
would call it the cumulative
cumulative record
um sly Cosby says zelenski is a once in
a lifetime leader may he live long and
the people have the freedom they do
rightly Reserve yeah I I don't see
zelenski as some heroic figure I just
see him as hey he's the president and
he's facing an invasion
from Russia and he didn't bail and he's
there and he's trying to defend the
sovereignty of his country's borders
that's it's it's not I don't need to
make this big moral judgment and you
know that clip we looked at from Lara
Logan earlier where she says your only
choices are you either wholeheartedly
defend everything about Ukraine and
zelenski or you're considered a Putin
apologist no that's not the case Russia
is in the wrong they are invading a
country not respecting its sovereignty
violating all sorts of international
agreements period
and then at the same time you can say
zelenski's not particularly qualified
there is a corruption problem in Ukraine
but it's still more of a democracy than
Russia and either way that wouldn't
justify a Russian invasion there's
plenty of room for nuance this is one of
the things that that the the people who
want to confuse you
will often say they'll say you're not
allowed to hold a nuanced view who's not
allowing it what are you talking about
you're perfectly allowed to have a
nuanced View
good morning sir Sam Cedar has been
advocating for the Naturalization of gas
in the U.S naturalization I don't even
know what that means
or do you mean nationalization listen we
just need to get off of gas
we need to get off of gas
Emily says does anybody have information
on the best way to help ukrainians with
disabilities
um I don't know the answer to that
I don't know the answer to that
David keep up the amazing work your
content is needed now more than ever
greetings from a former Hampshire County
resident thank you pierce I very much
appreciate that thank you thank you
thank you will I do another free item
from the store I don't know I don't know
about that
um let's do this okay so we're at 10 now
right we're at 10.
um anybody who between 10 and 20 pays
full price for a yearly membership I'll
give you a free item but you've got to
pay full price yearly otherwise we lose
money or we lose some people say we lose
money I say we lose
um you can also I mean listen just use
the coupon code the coupon code is a
disgusting discount listen these are the
types of things if you want to talk
about corruption in Ukraine the discount
when you use the code please don't war
is far more corrupt than anything I've
seen zielinski do
quite frankly and you can use that code
on my website everybody gets a shout out
but if you pay full price yearly I will
send you a free item for sure
do I have any unbanned requests let me
look at that we're getting a lot of
business done that streaming we're
really getting a start on the day by
streaming this early I like it I do have
a couple unbanned requests hold on let
me get my gavel
here we go
so a couple people have been banned from
twitch user based socialist was banned
after saying to someone Fu Grandma
privileged effing [ __ ] they were then
banned
their unbanned request is I was angry at
somebody for trying to equivocate third
world kids experience to that of middle
class Americans okay all right well
listen you're you're sort of taking
responsibility
uh I am gonna I'm gonna unban
if you want another shot user 990.
uh what did they do
user 990 said there are so many Nazi and
communist sleeper cells in the U.S you
could line them all up make a bridge to
the Moon why do you think American
doctors were eager to keep everyone
Stoned on opioids answer to hide commies
and Nazis with a weird spelling there
saved you a couple Grand on College
tuition part of an invasion of an
impenetrable nation in the Nazi book
anyway is to take complete control of
the psychological healing of said Nation
opioid stunt mental health and were
designed to be distributed and Mass to
hide Sleeper Cell Communists operating
in U.S they were banned
and then they said may I please ask for
a ban appeal yeah I mean this is this
this crazy stuff but it's not
particularly weaponized it's just dumb
uh they got a little out of hand but I'm
gonna unban that as well
I think I think I'm much more likely to
unban in the morning you know how judges
are more likely to give stricter
sentences when it's right before lunch
and they're hungry
for some reason I'm finding myself to be
more of a benevolent adjudicator of
bands uh during early morning streams
make of it what you will I don't know I
don't know where I don't know why
but
I'm not sure
can you briefly discuss the oranges and
social etymology of Obama oh yeah this
these are the oranges of Obama right
here check this out
gonna be in trouble big trouble remember
that oh Rock voted against the border
wall it's a good thing
and he voted for Obama
there it is those are the oranges of
obamna okay very very simple and
straightforward
thank you and welcome to Lord warsim
who just signed up via twitch Prime
twitch Prime
thank you
um let's see what else we've got thanks
to the 1.5 trillion dollar Omnibus Bill
we are now spending 20 billion a year on
Transit and 16 billion a year on rail
Amtrak great news thank you
Taylor says Ukraine has bio Labs so must
have bio weapons Ukraine has nuclear
plants so must have nukes I wonder where
the clown showed that Russian propaganda
ends gas stations so must have Molotov
cocktails yeah I mean they have gasoline
by definition if you've got gasoline
you've got Molotov cocktails very very
fair point
very fair point
um let's see what else we have here
let me see if I have do I have any other
voicemails for you let's see
I mean I have voicemails I don't know
that they're really
super interesting to you
a lot of them are from Whitney quite
frankly
so I was thinking about like scientific
and metaphorically about religion and um
oh boy here we go here we go let's go
live now to Capitol Hill
[Applause]
Now understand the standing ovations
have taken on a life of their own like
Canada gave a long-standing Ovation so
of course now the US does I mean it's
it's become its own it's it's become a
monster of its own creation the standing
ovations it's it's like it's it's taken
on a life of its own it's quite
incredible I think this is Mitt Romney
up here is it or maybe not
Hold On Let's uh
good morning Mr President good morning
Madam Ambassador who was with us this
morning Madam ambassador
ambassador matarova
Mr President it is my honor to present
to you the Congress of the United States
which has great respect and admiration
and appreciation for your courageous
leadership members of Congress I have
the high privilege and distinct honor of
presenting to you the president of
Ukraine Vladimir zielinski Slava ukrana
God bless
the United States
second standing ovation
Jesus
[Applause]
glory to Heroes
thank you very much
Madam speaker members of the Congress
ladies and gentlemen
Americans friends
I'm proud to greet you from Ukraine from
our capital city of cave a city that is
under missile and airstrikes from
Russian troops every day but it doesn't
give up
and we have not even thought about it
for a second just like many other cities
and communities in our beautiful country
which found themselves in the worst war
since World War II
I have the honor to greet you on behalf
of the Ukrainian people Brave and
freedom loving people who for eight
years have been resisting the Russian
aggression
those who give their best
Sons and Daughters to stop this
full-scale Russian invasion
right now the destiny of our country
is being decided the destiny of our
people whether ukrainians will be free
whether they will be able to preserve
their democracy Russia has attacked not
just us not just our land not just our
cities it went on a brutal offensive
against our values basic human values it
through tanks and planes against our
freedom against our right to live freely
in our own country choosing our own
future
against our desire for happiness against
our national dreams just like the same
dreams you have you Americans
just
like anyone else in the United States I
remember your National Memorial in
Rushmore
the faces of your prominent presidents
those who laid the foundation of the
United States of America as it is today
democracy Independence freedom and care
for everyone for every person for
everyone who works diligently who lives
honestly who respects the law we in
Ukraine want the same for our people
that is normal part of your own life
ladies and gentlemen friends Americans
in your great history you have pages
that would allow you to understand
ukrainians understand us now when you
need it right now when we need you right
now remember Pearl Harbor
terrible morning of December 7 1941 when
your sky was black from the planes
attacking you just remember it remember
September the 11th a terrible day in 20
2001 when evil knows the points to hit
for the American audience that's for
sure territories in battlefields when
innocent people were attacked
attacked from Air yes Mexico
just like nobody else expected it you
could not stop it our country experience
the same every day right now at this
moment every night for three weeks now
various Ukrainian cities
Russia has turned the Ukrainian Sky into
a source of death for thousands of
people
Russian troops have already fired nearly
1 000 missiles at Ukraine countless
bombs they use drones to kill us with
Precision this is a terror that Europe
has not seen has not seen for 80 years
and we are asking for a reply for an
answer to this uh Terror from the whole
world is there's a lot to ask for to
create a no-fly on Zone over Ukraine
asking for the no-fly zone
that's a big deal
no-fly zone something that Ukraine that
Russia would not be
is our free cities if this is too much
to ask we offer an alternative you know
what kind of Defense systems we need as
a 300 and other similar systems you know
how much depends on the battlefield on
the ability to use aircraft powerful
strong Air Aviation to protect our
people our freedom our land aircraft
that can help Ukraine
help Europe
and you know that they exist and you
have them but they are on Earth not in
Ukraine in the Ukrainian Sky they do not
defend our people I have a dream these
words are known to each of you today I
can say I have a need
I need to protect our Sky I need your
decision your health which means exactly
the same the same you feel when you hear
the words I have a dream wow ladies and
gentlemen
friends Ukraine is grateful to the
United States for its overwhelming
support for everything that your
government and your people have done for
us for weapons and ammunition for
training for finances for leadership in
the Free World which helps us to
pressure the aggressor economically I'm
grateful to President Biden for his
personal involvement for his sincere
commitment to the defense of Ukraine and
democracy all over the world I am
grateful to you for the resolution which
recognizes All Those who commit crimes
against Ukraine against the Ukrainian
people as war criminals however now it
is true in the darkest time for our
country for the whole Europe I call on
you to do more new packages of sanctions
are needed constantly every week until
the Russian military machine stops
restrictions are needed for everyone on
whom there's unjust relationship
we propose that the United States
sanctions all politicians in the Russian
Federation who remain in their offices
and do not
cut ties with those who are responsible
for the aggression against Ukraine from
State Dumas members to the last official
who has lack of morale to break the
state Terror all Americans company must
leave Russia from their Market leave
their Market
immediately this guy's making a lot of
Demands flooded with our blood ladies
and gentlemen requests
please take the lead if you have
companies in your districts the finance
the Russian military machine living
business in Russia you should put
pressure I'm asking to make sure that
the Russians do not receive a single
penny that they use to destroy people in
Ukraine
the destruction of our country the
destruction of Europe All American ports
should be closed for uh Russian Goods we
um Peace is more important than income
and we have to defend this principle in
the whole world we already became part
of the anti-war Coalition a big anti-war
Coalition that unites many countries
dozens of countries those who reacted to
in principle to President Putin's
decision to invade our country but we
need to move on and do more we need to
create new tools to respond quickly and
stop the war the full-scale Russian
invasion of Ukraine which began on
February 24th and it would be fair if it
ended in a day in 24 hours that evil
would be punished immediately today
day the world does not have
such tools the war of the past have
prompted our predecessors to create
institutions that should protect us from
war but they unfortunately don't work we
see it you see it so we need new ones
new institutions new alliances and we
offer them we propose to create an
association
U24 United for peace a union of
responsible countries that have the
strengths and Consciousness to stop
conflicts
all the necessary assistance in 24 hours
if necessary even weapons if necessary
sanctions humanitarian support political
support finances everything you need to
keep the peace and quickly
save the world to save lives in addition
such associations such unions could
provide assistance to those who are
experienced natural disasters man-made
disasters who felt victims to
humanitarian crisis or epidemics
remember how difficult it was for the
world to do the simplest thing just to
give vaccines vaccines against covet to
save lives to prevent new strains the
world spent months years doing things
like that much faster to make sure there
are no human losses no victims ladies
and gentlemen Americans if such Alliance
would exist today that is U24 we would
be able to save thousands of lives in
our country
in many countries of the world those who
need peace those who suffer inhumane
destruction I ask you to watch one video
video of what the Russian troops did in
our country in our land we have to stop
it we must prevent it preventively
destroy every single aggressor who seeks
to subjugate other nations please watch
I'm gonna step away I I just I don't
know if this is going to be gory and we
don't really want to have issues again
with uh with terms of service on various
elements of platforms so I'm just gonna
tune away let's just listen
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I would show it but you guys know
that there's a lot of people who want to
get us banned from all of our platforms
it's actually it's just kids running
around there's music a person is crying
uh a soldier's holding a baby
um there's a building getting blown up
there's a vehicle getting blown up
there's a kid crying there's a dad
walking with a baby there's a blown up
building there's another blown up
building
there's an ambulance oh God a good thing
I tuned away from this there's all sorts
of medical
elements blood dead children yeah it was
smart to tune away from this I would
definitely be getting banned uh oh my
God there's like uh like emergency
births of some kind Mass Graves people
being dumped in Mass Graves
uh
uh a grandmother being carried out by
EMTs
a mom with a baby blown up buildings
firefighters
crying
soldiers evacuating babies
oh man yeah I would have gotten banned
for this
that was a smart move wow people holding
hands
um black and white footage fires things
on fire a grandmother crying a pink
backpack being thrown around
cars on fire kids with tubes up their
noses grandmother in a wheelchair being
evacuated abandoned strollers
um
oh this is not good missiles dropping
um kids being given water
buildings blown up 20 babies in a room a
dad grieving his dead Child Hospital
scenes
very precarious Hospital scenes blood
and then a call to close the sky over
Ukraine
wow
making the case for a no-fly zone which
would be tantamount to World War III
today
it's not enough to be the leader of the
niche
the day it takes to be the leader of the
world being the leader of the world
means to be the leader of peace
peace in your country doesn't depend
anymore only on you and your people
it depends on those next to you
and those who are strong
doesn't mean big
strong is brave and ready to fight for
the life of his citizens and citizens of
the world
of human rights for freedom for the
right to live instantly and to die when
your time comes well
and not when it's wanted by someone else
by your neighbor
today the Ukrainian people are defending
not only Ukraine we are fighting for the
values of Europe and the world
sacrificing our lives in the name of the
future
that's why today the American people are
helping not just Ukraine
but Europe and the world to keep the
planet alive
to keep Justice in history
now I am almost 45 years old today my
age stopped when the heart of more than
100 children
stopped beating I see no sense in life
if it cannot stop the death
and this is my main mission at the
leader of my people great ukrainians
and at the leader of my Niche I am
addressing the President Biden
you are the leader
of the niche of your abbreviation
I wish you
to be the leader of the world
being the leader of the world means to
be the leader
of Peace wow thank you
Lord there it is
as you see Charles Schumer and Mitch
McConnell and Patrick Leahy there front
right and then Nancy Pelosi telling
whoever's next to her to stand the hell
up
uh the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski making a number of requests
including a no-fly zone including a
request for certain weapon systems
um without a doubt if everything he
asked for was done we would have
something much closer to World War III
than we have right now
without question see if there's anything
else
I guess that's a
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
calling on Congress to help his country
survive yeah wow wow what a speech and
uh it is
you know endless requests not
unreasonable if you are zelenski you've
got to shoot your shot
I don't know that the United States is
going to be willing to do those things
and we'll learn that probably in the
next several hours there will be
reactions to this what is happening in
Ukraine obviously horrifying devastating
unconscionable
and uh nobody denies that
that has any connection to reality I
guess maybe if you watch Fox you would
see some people deny that but
um very very serious uh
um requests there
and I don't know that the United States
is willing to do the thing about a
no-fly zone is the enforcement of a
no-fly zone and what you're talking
about is very scaled up military
activity
um
oh hold on a second it looks like we
have some
people we've got a ban here
oh yeah okay we've got a conspiracy
theorist here
saying
yeah
wow we are having to ban people almost
faster than the translator was was
translating thank you to Miguel Salazar
for signing up on my website welcome
Miguel I really appreciate that
appreciate everybody's Support also
thanks to xbroken for the twitch Prime
subscription
um yeah we're gonna see in the next I
know we might have to ban
we might have to ban bass I just unban
based socialist but their presence here
is just pretty toxic uh
just rapid firing messages
I don't know it's it's borderline it's
borderline
yeah okay we'll see we'll see about that
um
here's Jerry Nadler as you can see
taking in the sights and sounds of
what's taking place here I believe this
is Amy Klobuchar Nancy Pelosi here in
the background
um some very very serious high-level
discussions taking place here
okay well that's gonna do it guys thank
you for joining me we do have to move on
to producing today's podcast so we'll
have reaction to this and a lot of
different things later today I am on to
producing Today's show today's show
Obama thank you to everybody for joining
me and we will be back with you very
very soon